[Music]
it's no secret that we love the loud
house and we know you adore it too
holidays are coming so we thought we'd
make the loud house holiday gift guides
and show you what present we'd give to
every single loud sibling we're pretty
jealous of glorious gift don't forget to
hit that thumbs up button and subscribe
to our channel for more videos about the
loud house now let's check out the loud
house Holiday Gift Guide Lisa loud what
Christmas present could we give to the
four year old Lisa who seems to like
anything related to science we're
thinking about giving her something that
will make a fantastic addition to her
science lab something that will be
extremely beneficial for her new
discoveries a microscope perhaps or
maybe even a DVD of all seasons of
Dexter's Laboratory so she could meet
her Cartoon Network twin speaking of a
Dexter's Laboratory DVD is a perfect
gift for practically anyone whose
favorite character is Lisa her and
Dexter are pretty much the same people
and they even have the same big glasses
Lowell aloud next on our Christmas list
is the six-year-old Lola loud aka the
pageant queen we often compare it to
Elena Thompson also known as honey boo
boo but which present would you give to
Lola lab for Christmas we think she'd
absolutely love a new fabulous tiara
that's an upgrade from the one we always
fear where what do you think and if you
know someone who's Lola's biggest fan
you should definitely show them this
absolutely hilarious Lola shirt isn't
her smiles as the cutest thing you've
ever seen we want that shirt for
ourselves land aloud and if we talk
about Lola we of course can't forget
about her twin sister Lana who's just as
awesome unlike Lola Lana's in two
completely opposite things from her
sister she loves to play in mud or
repair things like toilets or any pipes
so we thought she loved out this huge
set of handyman tools she can use to
repair practically everything we're sure
she knows all of this stuff better than
we do if you have a handy person in your
family this would be a fantastic gift
for them to you know someone who would
appreciate this set of handyman tools
Lucy loud we always try not to pick
favorites in the loud house but we have
to admit that Lucy is one of our
definite favorites her dark and moody
personality has awesome comedic timing
and we absolutely adore her poems even
though they might make no sense because
Lucy loves poetry we thought she'd enjoy
a brand-new poetry book for her
collection we chose Emily Dickinson's
complete poetry book as we're sure she'd
get inspired
speaking up this would also be a
fantastic
for any other writers and poets who are
just completely in love with books
Lincoln loud and then there's the
protagonist of the story the 11 year old
Lincoln loud is definitely not your
typical 11 year old apart from being the
middle child he also has to deal with 10
sisters who are definitely a handful and
let's be honest sometimes winkin does
more work than his parents do we think
Lincoln could use some Zen and alone
time which is why we're giving him a
huge meditation cushion so he can
schedule some time outs for himself to
calm down from all this loud house noise
speaking of this is a fantastic present
for anyone who seems to be just a bit
too stressed in their life
Lin loud let's move on to the
competitive one every family has that
one person who will turn everything into
a competition which Ultimates it less
fun for everyone else and that's
definitely Lin's job in the loud house
she's super sporty and takes everything
seriously especially things that
involved sports and her winning first
place we're giving her a brand new
football so she can still get an a-plus
Pleasant kicks and get another trophy
for the loud trophy case got a friend
who loved soccer they probably love a
brand new soccer ball luan loud every
family has a comedian of course in those
families the dads tend to be the ones
who tell the most in pairs and dad jokes
but in the loud house it's LuAnn she's
also a total queen of pranks and you
really want to be out of her way on days
like April Fool's where Luann's pranks
have really hit a new level because
she's such a jokester we thought she'd
appreciate an air horn she can even make
a YouTube channel
film her air horn prank and share them
with us an air horn is also a great gift
for any one of your friends who wants to
step up their pranks although be aware
air horns come with consequences and you
might regret your buying decision later
Luna loud okay you caught us we said we
don't pick favorites but apart from Lucy
we always loved Lunas antics she's one
of the coolest characters ever her
fashion sense is awesome as is her music
case so what could we get her for
Christmas we're thinking she'd
appreciate something music related like
maybe a brand-new guitar with a
signature from one of the favorite
artists or even a microphone so she can
keep on practicing her singing if you
have a musician in the family or someone
who really loves music getting a
signature of their favorite artist will
absolutely bring a smile to their face
Lennie laughs and
now it's time for the oldest to of the
loud kids Lenny loud is a true
fashionista and she's one of the few
people that can pull up those big white
glasses and rock them like no no she
really knows her fashion so we thought
of giving her a makeup kit so she can
combine her love of fashion with her
love for makeup who knows you might see
Lenny on a model runway in the future if
you have someone who either loves makeup
or never has the time to get into it a
full kit is always a good idea for a
Christmas present Lauri loud Lauri is
the oldest of the family and apart from
Clyde it seems like a lot of fans don't
like it because she's so mean to her
siblings she loves privacy and she hates
when younger kids get in her way she's
also a complete Technology addict who
loves her phone more than anything so
what would you give Lauri for Christmas
we think she loved the brand new iPhone
X so she can spend even more time
talking to her boyfriend Bobby you have
a technology geek in the family who bet
they'd appreciate a brand new phone and
that's it for our video for more videos
about the loud house check out 10 the
loud house episodes that word for kids
see you next time
[Music]